all right joining us now with more
reaction we have the host of michelle
malkin investigates michelle malkin
former deputy assistant to the president
Fox News national security strategist
dr. Sebastian corker you know we've
talked a lot over the years Michelle and
he wrote a book about this about illegal
immigration in this country and you look
at all of those numbers and statistics
the one that stands out the most to me
is three point five percent of the
population estimate thirteen and a half
percent of crimes that's federal not
state local what what what part of this
is California the governor and the
Oakland mayor not getting well they get
it and they don't care and it's that
defiance
it's that recklessness it is that
sabotage of not only the sovereignty of
California but the sovereignty of this
country that they have sacrificed for
political and electoral gain they've
been doing it for decades and for Jerry
Brown to call Jeff Sessions and Donald
Trump's accountability for their actions
a stunt there's no bigger radical open
borders clown car than than the one that
is filled by these Democrat politicians
Jerry Brown who declared the the state a
sanctuary state with his raft of ten
different bills that undermine
enforcement of the law that prevent
employers and land Lords and citizens
and law enforcement from cooperating to
make sure that that state is safe then
you've had Xavier Becerra who I don't
know if you remember this Sean but in 15
years ago you interviewed him and he
proudly acknowledged his his membership
in one of the most radical open borders
organizations in America mecca whose
slogan is for the race their race
everything for people outside the race
nothing and now he's in this position of
power as well as a Oakland Mayor Libby
Schaaf sanctuary cities are outlaw
cities
sanctuary mayors and sanctuary governors
are out and we need to do more we
to do more than just hold them civilly
liable they need to be criminally liable
they need to be kicked off from behind
they're both bully pulpit and put behind
bars and and dr. Gork we're not talking
about daca which by the way President
Trump was willing to make a deal on daca
for the wall chain migration and the
visa lottery we're not talking about any
of them we're talking about criminal
illegal immigrants those that not only
broke our laws coming into the country
illegally
but then committed other crimes now if
you aid and abet in a system in getting
away from authorities the question is
simple are you then responsible for
whatever are the crimes they commit in
the future well of course you are
whether you're a governor or whether
you're a mayor you take an oath of
office and if you are acting in
contravention of the Supremacy Clause of
the US Constitution which gives federal
government the sole mandate to deal with
immigration then you are obstructing
justice and you may be aiding and
abetting felons it's a very simple
question does the governor of California
does the mayor of Oakland believe that
because they are politicians they are
above the law this is the Clinton
complex Sean
they think they're politicians therefore
the US Constitution and federal law does
not apply to them yes yeah well it's got
to apply to them and it's superseded
what they're doing in the say here's my
exit question for both of you
should should the Department of Justice
follow through and arrest the mayor of
Oakland because I assume that in the
minds of the left that will turn her
into a martyr the president is committed
to rule of law Sean he is not prepared
to see this happen again because when
you provide sanctuary let's look at who
you're providing it to you're providing
it to criminals the people we have to
protect our Americans and for the last
eight years
ice DHS CBP have been shackled they've
been handcuffed short we are allowing
them to do that job which is to a
pretends I wish these guys would go to
the drug warehouses that I've been to I
wish they were out with me
she actually was there when gang members
were arrested that same exit question
michelle malkin should those that made
in abet be arrested yes they absolutely
should be and I said this should just be
the start I mean we need to have
Attorney General Sessions here in
Colorado
we've got defiant outlaw politicians
right now in Denver and law enforcement
officers the police chief who refuses to
cooperate with ice there was a hit and
run illegal alien driver that they
refused to put an ice detainer on they
need to be behind bars we need to have
more than lawsuits we need to have
prosecutions alright thank you both
michelle malkin dr. korkor